we're back for day two here at Comic Con
Roxy Harold Holzer I'm like slurring my
snaps winces no they do did you build
your unikitty like right when you got
home I did I felt her so quickly but
honestly I couldn't even think of
anything else like I'm building this
girl so I'm kind of jealous because
yesterday you got the chance to get your
unikitty go play with the Legos I didn't
get to see the Turtles
so today you bought the turtles turtle
time the cables are Star Wars a pennant
is Han Solo we got a nice cute little
dress on
and I haven't been television our goal
also we need to put a backpack that's
actually my only goal today
so yes yeah I need a backpack okay
edit that out edit that out as well well
Rocky's doing your stand-ups come see
Lego
here it is sorry
so men
oh my gosh these are happy
folio up to that my gosh you look so you
look great oh this is so awesome
okay we just ran into chopper to the
biker dog and now we're about to go
check out I'm the brains of my behind
now we got the event I just
he took the selfie during my own trophy
- so yeah but Rodney that right now so
every selfie Sam selfie
thank you guys I can't even tell you
what just happened I got the most
amazing and Game of Thrones selfies with
the cast I hope I got almost samuel
l.jackson it was like a really great
selfie sesh even though I hate the word
selfie it's kind of become like a joke
should we take a selfie all right here
we go up to our intro meet up here at
nerd HQ we're gonna get some pictures
roasting process but we're giving away a
processor to say yes oh my god he hasn't
been you know
spaghetti and I hope it's not a long
wait and it's the only thing that I've
learned just one okay then I've had a
list of things that I wanted to do but
the Spaghetti Factory is boring I guess
you
and you look really familiar I do
civilian air no you just invited me to
like them on Facebook and guess what I
did like did you really shoot next week
really
you guys look I have your head cop he's
you're so tall thank you guys I'm sorry
Comic Con is made me so sleepy and I
just had a sangria and spaghetti that's
a resolution sleep
we will leave your backpacks because
what we found we found a backpack oh my
god
there you go wait Vega
ready for the meet up tomorrow we're
gonna go stop by Lego again a second
second trip today you could fall and
prepared with ice team t-shirt I mean
this is awesome
well I have many reasons but the most
important reason is that their videos
are beautiful reminder to just be
yourself so keep that my you know so
that you're out here for and I love you
know nice deep very funny tell you are
you gonna skate yeah well do that
do you want like pictures only to a
measure
this is what they revealed today oh my
gosh look at he's so angry Batman's and
we're super angry honey so I made a
little Lego store he was so sad I really
wanted this unikitty t-shirt and I
didn't get to come back yesterday to get
it so guess what I don't get t-shirt I
want something else what should we get
done what should I get
did she did tonight the buildings at a
party